vous savez que la fashion week est
annuel bah ouais mais bon moi qui suis
fashion moi j'adore les week j'adore la
flotte
j'en ai pris un coup sur la carafe jun
étage
alors pour remplacer la fashion week est
ce qu'on peut avoir un petit défilé
rapide des personnes les plus à même de
défiler alors vous me sens pas moi je
peux le faire
j'aimerais bien qu'on est allé à l'odre
et guillaume genton jallet voir
guillaume genton à mon avis c'est celle
[Rires]
là c'est que j'ai réalisé mes témoins
petite musique de défiler et d'accueil
énorme et est une idole prométhée
lottinghen comme on avait fait voile a
arrêté le passager la victime connue de
mort pour avoir l'air des agrafes ça je
sais faire c'est bon ça c'est dans mes
cordes âgées marpa base italienne a dit
daniel regarder ça ça défie sans témoin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec 10 et garde un tacle en touche vers
smeno mais je ne fais pas des écoutes
moi château dois je t'explique peut-être
que dans deux mois je vais peut-être sur
les podiums ou tu le fais on arrête
aujourd'hui au contrat et puis c'est
tout j'ai toutes les grandes marques qui
moi p1 la balance ce gars qui m'a appelé
pour toi tu joues c'est vrai bien sûr
c'est ouais ils m'ont dit balance à la
barre
[Rires]
exhibitionniste ce mec là je suis là tu
lâches dans un boîte c'est grâce à
l'allemagne revient pas ah non mais je
vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
l'éclaircie les transats mes frères
c'est pas patrick bruel c'est patrick
bonnel et m'a dit ah ouais ouais il ya
quelque chose à l'échelle on a quand
même dommage car ici dans l'équipe on a
la chance on a géré à dinéault dry non
pour moi non pour moi vous êtes
mannequins d'aujourd'hui on va quand
même on va quand même finir par audrey
je vous dis la vérité
juste pour une question d'audience
raconter l'histoire on va pas raconter
d'histoires aux téléspectateurs on n'est
pas là pour ça moi je dis la vérité
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
vérité est au bout du couloir à côté 24e
cas doit faire c'est pas parce que tu te
rends costume de tiquetac readynas effet
hall alors plus r'n'b
aulas
[Applaudissements]
normalement et là le mec qui dit perdure
elle a rien perdu rien perdu mais c'est
vrai que normalement il ya des mecs qui
disent de elle porte un pantalon
hiroshi je sais je ne connaissais rien
dis-moi yohji yamamoto frère et demandé
une paire de chaussettes à 1510 vie de
ma mère tapeta diffus mais la paire de
chaussettes suis d'abord bar mitzvah
planète comme à un fly aussi yamamoto
faire ça mais ça et nous les moches on
n'a pas le droit
alors déjà déjà vous n'êtes pas moche
déjà on n'est pas moche vous êtes ingrat
ça n'a rien à voir
les audiences pourraient alors audrey on
va le faire mais de pas tout de suite
chez mega c'est parti allez y aurait
[Musique]
assez beau ah ouais ça me ramène ta
table
[Applaudissements]
sam et de légumes
les guides vous va traîner ça vous plaît
j'étais pas pour c'est vrai vous êtes
super un fuseau weng li na ne crois pas
que basquiat presse epa faudrait je me
suis penché ce week end à un boulot ou
plantes cgt boulot boulot boulot et je
me suis penché sur la ville audrey ah
ouais la vie dorée notre nouvelle venue
l'odre j'ai vu vous aviez des soucis
avec votre douche parce qu'il ya
apparemment il n'ya pas de regarder ces
mets ça sur instinct mais sa passe est
sa tombe à côté en fait la cool bah oui
faut se mettre dans des colères quoi
voilà quoi
parce que moi je suis dans la plomberie
donc forcément ça va c'est quand il y en
a interpellé jb vous avez acheté un
ficus oui aussi bas c'est ouais c'est
pas parce qu'à l'aller va troquer les
jardinautes elle présentait son père ni
sa mère condamnée y va tranquille en
soit vous avez vu c'est le vendée globe
ouais vous intéresser aux sports on vous
a vu guetter l'arrivée
[Rires]
j'aime la lame est ce important il ya
aussi audrey je sens qu'on va bientôt
voir dans koh lanta vous n'avez pas bien
compris l'épreuve des poteaux regarder
enfin je veux dire ça c'est
hyperimportant fait le chez vous aussi
il faut toujours vérifier l'inclinaison
de sa rampe d'escalier à audrey
bricoleuse ont regardé voilà toujours
importante action n'est vraiment pas si
on doit être vingt dix degrés magnifique
sel et e
je vous le dis cyril c'est juste une
question vous vous êtes évidemment ce
qui est normal un terrain excusez moi
les gens qui parlent un compte il j'ai
joué du gros 24 dans la tête vous
plaisir
elle est belle votre france si c'est ça
votre pensée bah c'est pas la guerre non
je te disais vous vous êtes et c'est
tout à votre honneur évidemment c'est la
nouvelle venue et donc vous avez bien
sûr le travail de patron de windsor si
vous avez fait de même avec chacun
d'entre nous a dit regardez bien sûr
tout le monde assure j'ai vu l'instar de
tout le monde sinon je me suis désabonné
[Rires]
audrey donc sachez le je vous suis sûr
instant à ça y est c'est officiel
ça y est vous pouvez le dire à vos amis
ça y est ça viendra donner c'est tombé
dans votre jeu